One of the most common questions I get asked
is, "Pat, what is really the difference between
a goal and a vision.
Is there really one?
Isn't it the same thing?
If it's different, what's different?"
So I took time and we wrote down some notes
on what is the difference between a goal and
a vision.
And I'm going to get right into it because
the reality part of it is that there is a
very big difference.
There's a very, very big difference between
a goal and a vision.
Very big difference between a goal and a vision.
I think the question sometimes people ought
to ask is, "Can a goal oriented person be
as good of a visionary -- can they really
be a great visionary -- and can a visionary
be an incredible goal setter?
That's what we're going to talk about today.
So first, let's talk about the difference
between a goal setter and a visionary.
The one thing about a goal setter is this.
Goal setters set a goal, and a goal typically
has a life span.
Right?
So, for instance, I want to reach this goal
by this time and and I want to do this.
I want to make $100,000 by this time.
I want to buy a house by this time.
I want to go and drive this car one day.
I want to buy myself a Porsche.
Where a vision and a visionary doesn't have
a life span.
There is no deadline to it.
It keeps going.
There's no deadline.
So goal, short term, vision, long term.
Lifespan [goal] no lifespan [vision] deadline
[goal], no deadline [vision] -- it continues
to go.
That's one of the things that you've got to
keep in mind about the differences.
The other thing about goal vs. vision, a goal
is a checklist.
For instance, I have to do boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom to get this, right?
I have to do.
. . to reach this goal.
That's what I have to do.
A vision is a mission.
We HAVE to do this.
This has got to take place.
We can do this better.
This is by far the way it needs to get done.
This is the right way of doing this thing.
We're going to correct and adjust.
We're going to make this a better platform.
We're going to make it a better experience.
But the visionary doesn't have 17 different
steps.
The goal setter says, "Okay [snap], here's
what we need to do - dot, dot, dot, dot dot."
Okay, that's goal, this is vision.
Checklist [goal] mission [vision].
There's a big difference between a goal and
a vision.
Next one.
Goal setters are great at being directional.
Which is exactly what I just said with checklists,
but it's directional.
First let's talk to that person and then let's
call this person then let's do this, okay?
That's what a goal oriented person will say
on the directions of what to do next.
A visionary will paint a picture is what they'll
do.
Let me tell you what it looks like if we do
this.
Here's what it's going to look like.
Can you imagine if one day we have bop, bop,
bop, bop, bop.
Can you imagine if we do this, this, this
part.
Goal is going to say directional.
If we want to do this, we've got to talk to
these other people.
Then we go and get it done.
Here's another thing.
Goal is deadline, visionary can't stop talking
about it.
You know if you're a goal setter more or a
visionary if you only talk about the next
goal to hit and it's always what needs to
get done to hit that goal, you're more of
a goal-setter type.
If you can't help yourself but constantly
paint a picture of what it will look like
if we get it done -- feel, emotion, all of
that -- you're the visionary type.
And that's the one part you've got to keep
in mind with the goal setter and the visionary,
right?
And the last one is just simple to keep in
mind, you have logic [goal setter], you have
dream [visionary].
It's pure logic, here's what we need to do,
here's what takes place with this, [goal setter]
and you have the dream [visionary] that takes
place.
Now, both are important.
So this is not a message for me to say where
it's about, well, you know, the person who
sets goals is not as important as the visionary.
Absolutely ludicrous to make that statement.
I want to say that I'm not making that statement.
One is just as important as the other one.
This is the challenge though sometimes with
goal setters.
Here's the challenge with goal setters.
Those who are typically goal driven people
tend to sometimes slow down and sabotage themselves
and revert back to bad habits.
Because they already reached the goal, so
now they're bored, right?
Because goals have deadlines.
They have a short lifespan.
The goal can be achieved and then you're kind
of like, "Well, what do I do next?"
Right?
What do I do next?
You don't need to worry about that with Elon
Musk, because Elon Musk is not a goal-driven
guy.
He's a vision-driven guy.
You don't need to worry about that with Jobs.
You don't need to worry about that with Bezos
or the Google guys or certain coaches that
just cannot stop coaching because it's not
just about a goal, it's about a vision of
what organization we can build and who we
can become, and why the Yankees are the greatest
organization because we're going to change
the way that people look at the game of baseball
and we're going to make the world realize
that baseball is the greatest sport in the
world.
A certain soccer athlete is going to be like,
the greatest sport in the world is soccer
because when you grow up with kids and all
these kids growing up, the first thing you
do is throw them a ball and the ball is on
the ground and it touches your feet first.
To touch your hands you've got to pick it
up.
A ball is not meant to touch your hands.
They're selling you the vision of the game
of soccer.
Where the logical guy, the goal-setter guy
is going to say, no, here's how you play the
game the right way.
You've got to position like this and you've
got to kick like this and when you kick it's
got to be here and when you do the header
it's got to be.
. . that's the logic side.
So the defense has got to be.
. . that's the logical side, right?
So can one go without the other?
Absolutely not.
So here's the thing about goal vs. vision.
The goal setters need a visionary to team
up with.
The visionaries need to surround themselves
with goal setters.
Because if one doesn't do the other, that
won't become a reality.
One will not become a reality without the
other.
There's somebody that casts a vision, there's
another one that says, "Here's how we do it."
The person who is, "here's how we do it,"
will get bored.
This is why it's very critical for them to
always team up with a visionary.
A lot of times visionaries try so hard to
become goal setting type of people.
So hard.
And they'll never even come this close to
great goal setters.
And goal setters try so hard to become visionaries
and they fail every single time.
Why?
Because they can talk like a visionary for
one day, they can cast a vision for two days,
three, four, five, six, seven, ten days later,
all they're talking about is what?
Logic and the next goal.
Makes sense?
They forget that their real thing is the vision.
You don't need to tell the visionary to talk
about the vision.
What you need to tell the visionary is, "here's
the next goal.
What do we do next?
What do we have to do next?
What is the next goal?"
That's what the visionary needs to be talked
to about . In order to have the vision become
a reality, what are the next.
. . what do we need to do in the next six
months.
Next month, 12 months, 24 months.
That's what they need.
So even though -- I want you to know this.
This is not -- sometimes people will say,
"Well that's why I'm the vision guy.
I don't deal with minutia."
Nonsense.
You're making excuses.
You're justifying why you don't want to improve
in an area of goal setting.
I am probably not the most organized person
you'll ever meet.
If you look at my desk right now, it's messy.
I'm not the most organized person you'll ever
meet.
In my mind, it's very clear on what vision
- I already see the movie.
I've already seen the movie.
I've seen the movie over and over and over
again and I've explained the movie to tens
of thousands of people over and over.
To me, it's clear.
I've already seen it.
I've already seen exactly, I've felt it.
I've felt how people reacted when they see
the vision becoming a reality.
I've seen the impact it makes around the world.
In my mind, I've seen it.
I've seen it.
That's why I need a lot of help, to help this
vision become a reality.
But I can still become a better goal setter.
I can still improve in my goal setting abilities.
I can still sit down and grab a paper and
pen and say, "What is the next goal?
What are the next things that we need to do
to get to this vision?
Just like a goal-setting person can create
a reminder in their phone or all around them
-- maybe a vision board -- to always talk
about the vision.
To have somebody that reminds them about the
vision.
To have somebody that tells them where we're
going long term.
To have somebody that doesn't just focus on
the short-term.
Both people can improve.
But no matter how much you improve -- if you're
a goal-setting type, you will never be a natural
visionary -- as good of a natural visionary.
If you're a natural visionary type of person,
you will never be as organized as a goal-setting
person that's directional, that knows what
needs to get done.
Next, regardless, find them, team up together,
and the world is yours, based on how hard
you work and how long you guys can work together
as a team.
So, the question, the difference between a
goal setter and a visionary, that's my thoughts.
If you've got any questions about it, comment
on the bottom with your questions.
I do get back to everybody, with the questions
that you guys pose.
If you haven't subscribed to this channel,
please do so.
Our goal is to get to 100,000 subs by August
31.
We've already crossed 50,000.
We want to get to 100,000 by August 31, so
make sure wherever this is at, it's different
on different pages on YouTube, and if you
saw this video on a completely different website,
you can always come back to PatrickBetDavid.com
- there we go -- to see all the other content
that we have on PatrickBetDavid.com.
Thanks for watching, everybody.
Take care, bye bye.